Let's get some rational numbers.
I use this word because it is used in this book,
but in the more popular terminology we will "collect fractions".
Let's go through all these,
just to see all the examples.
First we will have 3/7 + 2/7.
Denominators are the same,
so we can just collect the numerators.
Our denominator is 7, and 3 plus 2 is 5.
This is an example 'a'.
Let me decide on one.
It will take an eternity to solve all.
Not for eternity, but more than I want.
Example 'c' is 5/16 + 5/12.
Our denominators are not the same.
We will have to find a common denominator that should be
at least in general - in fact, it may be every common fold
to these, but to make it easier to find
at least in total.
Which is the smallest number that is multiple
and at 16, and at 21?
Let's see, 16 in 2 is 32, we have not found it yet.
Three is 48.
This seems to work.
12 enters 4 times at 48.
Let us use 48 as a common denominator.
We had to multiply by 16 to 3 to get 48,
so we'll have to multiply this by 5.
We just multiply the numerator and the denominator
on the same number, do not change the value of the liver.
5 by 3 is equal to 15.
And then, to get from 12 to 48 here,
we have multiplied by 4.
Then, to get from 5 to this numerator here,
we need to multiply again by 4.
5 in 4 is 20.
Now we have the same denominator.
This will be equal to - our denominator is 48.
And then we can get 15 plus 20, which is 35.
And can we shorten this?
Let's see, 5 does not divide 48.
7 does not divide 48.
We seem ready.
Let's solve the example 'e'.
8/25 + 7/10.
Again, we do not have a common denominator.
But we can solve this.
Let's see, 50 is the smallest number,
which is a multiple of both.
25 by 2, it's 50.
8/20 to get to 50, multiply by 2.
We will have to multiply by 8 as well.
That would be 16/50.
And then 7/10, we want
to put it on 50.
We multiply 10 by 5, so
we have to multiply by 7 by 5.
This will be 35/50.
Now the denominators are the same, they are 50.
How many is 16 plus 35?
10 plus 35 is 45, plus 6, is 51.
This is 51/50.
Example 'g'.
Let me do it in another color.
Here we have 7/15 - I will write this second
in a different color - plus 2/9.
Again, the denominators are different.
We find a common denominator.
What is the smallest number, which is a multiple of 15 and of 9?
Let's see, 15 by 2 is 30.
No, do not divide at 9.
15 by 3 is 45, this works.
45 is divided into 9.
So we'll use 45.
15 in 3 is 45 and 7 in 3 is 21.
These two fractions are equivalent.
Plus - we'll have 45.
To get from 9 to 45, we need to multiply by 5.
So to get our numerator here,
we have to multiply by 5.
2 in 5 is 10.
2/9 is the same as 10/25.
Now we can collect them.
We collect fractions with a denominator 45.
21 plus 10 is 31, and we're ready.
Let's do another task, a text task.
"Nadia, Peter and Ian collect their money,
to buy one gallon of ice cream.
Nadya is the largest and gets the most pocket.
It contributes 1/2 of the amount. "
That is Nadia contributes 1/2 of the amount.
This is Nadia here.
"Ian is next by age and contributes 1/3 of the amount."
Ian contributes 1/3.
This is Ian.
"Peter, the youngest, gets the least pocket and
contributes 1/4 of the amount. "
That is, Peter gives 1/4 of the sum,
Peter contributes 1/4 of the amount.
"They calculated that this would be enough money.
When they reached the cash desk, they realized they had forgotten about VAT
and worried that there would not be enough money.
For amazement, they had the right amount of money.
How much of the price of ice cream has been added as a tax? "
Let's see if we collect 1/2 + 1/3 + 1/4 of the sum,
let's see how much we get.
We need to find a common denominator,
that is to say, at least a total of a multiple of 2, 3 and 4.
Let's see ... it will have to be 12.
12 is a multiple of 2, multiple is 3
and is a multiple of 4.
That is 1/2 is the same as 6/12.
2 by 6 is 12.
1 in 6 is 6.
These are equivalent.
6 is 1/2 out of 12.
1/3, if we use 12 as a common denominator,
to get from 3 to 12, we must multiply by 4.
You take this 4 and multiply it by 1.
4/12 is the same as 1/3.
And then 1/4, if you use denominator 12,
to get from 4 to 12, you must multiply by 3,
so we multiply the numerator by 3
and we get 3.
Let's get them together.
6/12 + 4/12 + 3/12 will be equal to -
our denominator will be 12, and the numerator is 6 + 4 + 3,
which is equal to - 6 plus 4 is 10, plus 3, is 13.
This will be equal to 13/12.
And this is an irregular liver.
Or we can say it's the same thing - it's equal
on 12/12 + 1/12, or we can say it's the same thing as -
12/12 is just 1.
12, divided by 12, is 1.
This is 1 whole and 1/12.
When they collected their money,
they received 1 whole and 1/12 of the price of ice cream,
who they wanted to buy.
And they ask:
"what part of the price of ice cream has been added as a tax?"
This is the exact amount they had to pay.
So, obviously, 1 is the price of ice cream without tax,
that is 1/12 is the amount added as a tax.
The answer to the question is 1/12 of the price
has been added as a tax.